jennifer paredes cuñada del presidente
pedro castillo es prófuga de la justicia
peruana por eso la fiscalía y un equipo
de la policía allanaron la casa del
mandatario que se encuentra en el centro
poblado de chur en la región cajamarca
en la diligencia se cumplió la orden de
descerraje las autoridades ingresaron a
la vivienda pero no encontraron a
paredes su rebeldía a colaborar con la
justicia podría motivar a la fiscalía
ordenar una prisión preventiva contra
ella por nueve meses según algunos
expertos por su parte el presidente
pedro casi o durante una reunión con
representantes de rondas campesinas
arremetió nuevamente contra el congreso
y sus opositores a quienes acusó de
hacer creer a los peruanos que el
presidente ha robado al país y que su
círculo familiar es igual a otros que
según pedro casi o saquearon al perú
mientras tanto desde el parlamento se ha
solicitado al jefe de la casa militar
las imágenes de las cámaras de seguridad
que registran los accesos al palacio de
gobierno y la residencia presidencial en
paralelo la ex presidenta del congreso
maría del carmen alba a través de sus
redes sociales criticó a pedro casi o el
exigió dejar de obstaculizar a la
justicia y renunciar al cargo
y hablando de renuncias vendí espinoza
abogado del presidente pedro castillo
renunció a seguir ejerciendo su defensa
he tomado la decisión de renunciar a la
defensa del señor presidente y la
primera dama reveló el abogado a través
de sus redes sociales